I saw the contrast between critics movie
reviewers movie fans who have seen
Prometheus it's pretty vast people like
it people hate it what to think don't
worry I'm here to set the record
straight prometheus
eisah Prometheus is directed by Ridley
Scott and it takes place in the world
the universe of alien the Prometheus is
not an alien prequel it's not just
saying that I will say that now it's not
an alien prequel so don't go into this
movie thinking it's an alien prequel
it's not and it follows a science crew
on the ship Prometheus who are convinced
alike we have found where the origin of
us came from came from that planet so
let's go say hi after that they land on
this planet and they're like let's
explore and then bad [ __ ] happens and
now you have the movie prometheus I mean
they're on the planet then they're on
the ship and things are going after them
and there's parasites problem is you've
seen this premise in sci-fi movies
before visually the movie looks awesome
really good camerawork I mean the props
are big or even if they are props
probably CGI at this point I'm gonna
call them props cuz I'm old-school but
it does it looks great everything is
like really big you're really interested
but then things start happening and then
IQ start dropping there's the scene I'm
not gonna get spoiler ash on you wear
this this life-form pops out of the
ground and they're all freaking out the
like good just life-form knows it's bad
I know it's bad because this is a sci-fi
movie that I'm in and it's a horror
movie I'm gonna die and then what does
he do
well he wants to poke at the thing and
touch it dude what are you doing it's
hissing at you like Europe you have a
PhD you were smarter than me I wouldn't
touch the thing someone dumber than you
is saying don't touch it and they're
right couple of performances in this
movie are really good like Idris Elba
good great even is one of my favorite
characters in the entire movie The
Dude's a really talented actor he
switches voices and accents and
everything he's in and prometheus he's
like southern oh that broke we're gonna
you're gonna love on that guy's a good
actor other one Michael Fassbender this
dude kills it and everything I love his
character David David's the synthetic
Android on the ship synthetic Android
that sounded smart when I say edible
cheeseburgers just do double speak in my
show
I thought his dialogue was great it was
delivered by him great The Dude's a
great actor great character I love the
character David other than that you have
a crew of pretty much expendable income
the moment
all that prometheus has a crew of 17
people I was like alright we got some
people that are going to bite it big and
yeah they're going to die and I'm not
going to care so we have a sci-fi horror
movie taking place on a planet where
parasites are trying to kill people with
a surplus of crew that you know you just
watch die because that's what they're
there for they're there to die starting
to sound like a basic sci-fi horror
movie one of the intriguing factors and
you can't help but think about it is the
fact that it does take place in the same
reality that the movie alien does you
try not to think about it you can't help
but think about it but really if you
take that away and just watch the movie
for what it is it's a basic sci-fi
horror movie where people die and people
get scared and then people die have you
seen that before yeah you have it's like
a few times your perception of the movie
changes sometimes you're like ah this is
really intense I like this other times
you're like is that a baby Sharktopus
what is that and you're like I like that
character I like the acting this is good
then you're like don't be stupid
scientists do don't be stupid at a point
in this movie I was like I am watching a
movie about a space on B it felt like
Wiggly Scott presents the space zombie
it only lasts for a little while but
that's kind of my point you go from like
in the movie to not like in the movie so
many times you walk out going did I like
it or did I not in the end I will say
it's a good time no alcohol required I
enjoyed it I had fun with it it's a cool
sci-fi but in the end there's nothing
really special about it it's a cool
sci-fi I can say this this movie does
set up for a sequel and I'm interested
to see the sequel and I'm gonna get a
little spoiler ish because I just want
to talk about this don't worry when you
see spoiler alert disappear you can turn
the sound back on in your computer
unless you just want to hear what I have
to say in which case a cool PC from the
trailer there's that big guy doing
things in the trailer you know he's just
a big giant walking around you're like
he's an [ __ ] he really is so why is
he an [ __ ] like why is he [ __ ] out
is there a reason
does he just disdain anyone smaller than
him is it because we're human beings is
it a hate crime like that why is he a
douche you never really know you feel
like they're gonna explain it in a
sequel but who knows they might not make
a sequel because all I'm doing is
watching a dude douche out on a bunch of
human beings and I don't know why
alright so have you seen Prometheus what
did you think about it are you one of
the people who loves it or one of the
people who hates it or you look in
between where you like a sci-fi horror
but you know that's what it is whoever
you are whatever your thoughts comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you